the message has been the same there has
to be some semblance of a cover-up the
residents have not been given the
correct information in a timely and
efficient manner not enough people have
been given enough funds to successfully
relocate for a safe amount of time
and the relocation payments of people
for evacuation was only in a one mile
radius meanwhile you're seeing dead fish
all the way out to Cincinnati you're
seeing the water contaminated in
Youngstown this goes on for hundreds of
miles Beyond this one mile radius
contamination Zone
so there are a lot of residents even in
this town that are not receiving the
help that they need so that's why we're
here at valuetainment we're actually
talking the residents we're telling
people how they can help and we're
getting the truth because quite frankly
if you listen to any governmental entity
Republican or Democratic doesn't matter
a lot has been left off the table in
terms of what they're telling us
so that's why we're here and
a lot of people are too scared to do
this
here's something interesting what will
happen
this is the actual water
tastes like metal
and that's thing reporter doesn't come
here and actually taste the water for
themselves
that water right now tasted like
somebody dropped about a million pennies
into it has that tinny almost blood-like
taste now I'm not going to drink a whole
glass
what you saw with the as I cut my hands
the water that I did have and just in
case you didn't see it before
this is the iridescent color
this is the water
look
terrible
well this is why we need to go here to
the river and actually look at
What's Happening Here
oh that you could see
you can even see the cup look at the app
right there
see the iridescent colors you're saying
that color is a mix of stuff oil which
hasn't been talked about that much no
they um my understanding is there was 60
000 gallons of oil that was spilled that
day and nobody's bringing it up at all
and then you got the 128 000 gallons of
uh that phos Gene mixed with Benzene I
mean it's
we're screwed all these houses are
compromised I mean I think everywhere
around here compromise within 10 miles
that stuff lift the stuff that you see
on the streets leaking today that was
from our homes and from the grass there
was no one mile evacuation zone for
pollution they shot it in it they let it
cook on its own for three days it wasn't
cooking all fast so five five containers
burned for three days it was not cooking
all fast enough so they made this grand
scheme to do a controlled burn
so that they could get the railroad
running faster because as soon as it
wasn't 32 hours later after that after
the controlled burn that they were down
there and running trains again even
before we made it in our homes from the
evacuation order that was lifted what
are we looking at right now this is so
what we're looking at is an area that
anytime that the creek swells which is
only about nine inches right now but it
swells up to usually three and a half to
four feet and it will come into our
basement and the toxologists from the
railroad told us that every time it
comes to the basement the vapors
eventually will rise and there's nowhere
for them to rise but to what is my bait
what is my bedroom and my child's
bedroom right above this exact spot my
real concern is my value of my house you
know I'm a single mother you know and
um you know I always thought well I
don't have nobody financially to fall
back on and if anything then I have my
house to fall back on before this
happened my house was probably worth
double what I owe now I would be lucky
to get what I owe
so I don't have that security to fall
back on that's that's a new angle you
just gave me is the economic for for
allowing definitely yeah that's that's
true definitely super super crucial you
have any messages uh Pete bootage is
just planning on visiting
um I hear he's coming tomorrow
um I think it's a little too late um he
should have been the first one here
being that he is Secretary of
Transportation he should have been here
first and um so now I just think it's a
joke for him coming I think now EPA the
federal EPA and FEMA Butte or however
you say his name or whatever I think
it's all because trumpet came you know
and it's all about well we can't let him
show us up no he ain't trying to show
you up he's showing that he cares and do
you feel safe in your neck of the woods
right now
well I'm feeling a lot better president
Trump is here let me tell you that uh do
you think it's okay to drink the water
oh man you could not pay me enough money
in the world to drink a glass of water
coming out of down here I mean just even
look at just right now you can see that
there is
what what is that oil uh chemicals uh
yeah no no thanks yeah there's a lot of
Cl you've been seeing this everywhere
the National Guard isn't here to help
people
the presidential Administration hasn't
been helpful
so it entirely falls on the residents
with little Financial Resources but they
are at least giving people the water
they need the supplies they need we met
people like Chris someone from the
Salvation Army someone from Amazon local
residents residents from all around Ohio
and Pennsylvania have driven hours to
get here those are the heroes of the day
and the people you need to ask questions
about have been
the governmental entities on both sides
so stay tuned and reporting for
valuetainment I'm Dodge lannisman can't
Dodge the truth